csgo's antwerp major has regrettably
come to a close
what isn't regrettable is
literally anything else about it it was
an absolute
banger we laughed we cried we cheered we
begged for graffitis
and for the first time as an
international roster hoisted a major
trophy
we
phased up
i can't believe i just did that on
camera
[Music]
okay so before we dive into the hallowed
high pass weekend of counter strike we
just beheld i'm i'm gonna do a weird
thing and i'm i'm gonna talk about
valorant specifically the vct watch
parties that liz has been hosting and
will continue to host this weekend on
our twitch channel they're a riot so if
you're at all into professional
valorante be sure to tune into twitch.tv
slash the score esports so you can watch
liz curse people listen a proto doesn't
lose this or a big kill to make things a
1v1 still holding on to it
my lord it's more
all right all right back to cs this past
weekend pgl's altogether very epic
antwerp major saw an altogether very
epic end as tournament favorites faze
clan became csgo's first ever
internationally sourced major winner he
gets his nerdy
[Applause]
now for those who've been following faze
clan for quite some time
you know what a big deal this is since
2016 this orc has been trying to cobble
together a multinational super team that
could achieve counter-strike's highest
honor and for six years with some of the
biggest names the game has to offer
they have failed from keo and alu to
olaf guardian and nico to freaking
coldzera and kiarby faze have never ever
been able to bag the big one and as we
north american fans know all too well
they've come
they've come pretty close
yeah
run the boston club look at the time
there's seven seconds got a bomb they're
trying to build pyramids but it's no
more crying
stewie's running around we're going over
time
but i think most of us can agree that as
soon as they nabbed csgo's native son
back in january of this year it felt as
if something had changed and
lo and behold
it did with kerrigan back at the helm
the rock that is rain at his side and
the trio of interrents that is twists
rops and brokey faze earned back-to-back
titles at iem katowice and epl season 15
cementing them as world number one
favorites going into antwerp where as
mentioned the bastards
finally did it
[Applause]
i'm not the biggest fan of faze as an
org but watching this select group of
competitors finally get their names
etched onto a major trophy
was nothing short of magical rops
finding the roster of his dreams reigns
sticking it out as the only 2016 og
member of the roster
kerrigan exercising his boston demons
brokey not only getting stickers but
champion ones to boots
and twists coming back from the brink to
earn north america their second major
cac w
this one was truly
for the history books you joined this
team you come back in with carrigan
you're on top of the world you're the
number one team but this certainly
wasn't easy but you just did it in two
and got your first major championship
how do you describe that brother
you cannot
it's just dreams come true for every
single one of us also speaking of twists
is it not fair to say that he's sort of
taken the title of any goat from stewie
like they both have a slam they both
have a pro-league final they now both
have a major but twists has the added
bonus of a katavitsa like
isn't the title just kind of his now if
you know me you know that i am something
of a simple shill and actually a huge
navi fan dating back to like 2011. so
i was very happy to see his goatness
grace a fourth major final with his
presence especially since if you ask me
depending on if this one single gun
fight had gone differently i think the
series could have as well but they're
running straight into the magnificent
fat token and with a wave of his walk he
gets one
simple though can end it right here
right now in a one-on-one a battle of
wits between him man robs is he
[Applause]
i am not taking anything away from phase
they played lights out and d e
underscore stroyed navi on nuke
but i think that if simple doesn't have
his knife out and actually wins his one
against robs here on inferno after being
down eight nothing
faze's mental could have been chalked
you can see it on reign's face man he
knew that that was a close one needless
to say i was not thrilled to watch navi
lose since fandom aside
i actually have a bit of a confession to
make avid consumers of our brand new
social series hot retakes which hey
shameless plug be sure to check out
might recall that when prompted i like
many others did actually predict phase
to win the major who are you picking to
win the antwerp major i think i honestly
think that faze are going to show up big
i think they're obviously an incredible
team i think that they are striving so
well right now they just have that magic
that like a winning team needs to have
unfortunately in spite of my infallible
wisdom
i didn't actually have the courage to
put them winning it all
in my pickums navi looked so
ridiculously good coming out of legends
that i caved and at the last minute
chose them to carry the hopes and dreams
of my challenge coin suffice it to say i
fell one single pick short of diamond
and want to scream into a pillow but if
i was going to sacrifice el diamante for
anything
i'm glad it was face
these guys earned it as for the rest of
the major
it was stellar and the matches were sick
the crowd was insane the talent did an
unbelievable job of making it all come
together
hell even the stickers were nice all in
all a formidable event that just made me
want to [ __ ] bleed counter strike
just please for the love of god
don't ask me to talk about liquid
the joke on twitter on the weekend was
um na has won their second major like
twist has earned north america at second
major but the best one i've i saw end of
2018 or something faze clan lent out
kerrigan for one month he played for a
north american roster named team envy
and people plastered that on twitter and
they were saying no kerrigan's na2 bro
like
we got two n a major winners on face
clan yeah